tu vas faire exactement ce que je te dis
ça il n'y aura pas d'embrouillé l'école
c'est pas vrai le maire de lyon une
patate si tu coupes les doigts ça fait
des frites je travaille la terre vous
non alors tu fais pas je m'occupe des
bonshommes bien cadeau pour toi
bonjour il est devenu ma soeur les rares
aux pour qu'elle vienne s'occuper de toi
jusqu'à noël qui suit on prendrait tout
c'est un travail ce que mes démons sol
et clément cadeau va pas il avoue par
jour les lacs les renvoyer des bois vous
allez dernier ressort
oui en plus c'est une professionnelle
dans ton plus marrante 800 mais c'est
pendant les heures fera que j'ai
vraiment besoin grâce au tiff
oh ça va
vous pouvez pas lui dire des trucs leurs
mots tortiller du cul devant elle quitta
journée comprend pas cette année dans
l'air comme ça mais c'est un type bien
et si tout n'est que tu assures sur les
doigts du cul ouais très très doux
c'est là parfois je me sens important
quelques banger je pensais qu'à fuir son
glas sonne
filmé à nos oreilles
chaque smartphone pierre cohen d'avian
doit partir
mais quoi
à meymac c'est tout le matin je sais de
lui dire qu'il demande hervé joly de la
cantine
nous venons
ma fille s'est mis en tête vos fleurs
roses pour nos assises en nous offrant
rose pour noël